all right
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you don't know about the singer
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
I always offered a second bite to the
guests oh yeah
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
alright alright that was a good oh yeah
yeah I've never some people are excited
about it some people can actually sing
so they grab it and they're like oh [ __ ]
this is my time cuz because when you
hear effects on a mic studio you know
we'll go to it occasionally but dude
thanks for coming in thank you man I
know I haven't see could you so damn
busy
you know this whole New York la this yes
I know but you've been working and doing
some really good things and I'm glad I'm
glad I got you on here now because I you
you're big but I feel like you're bout
to blow up man did I not know not as
much as we recorded this recording this
on a Saturday right just a Saturday yes
Saturday last night Kawhi Leonard signed
with the Los Angeles Clippers dude the
guys to you man I know you didn't stick
you know with the Clippers so I am
admittedly I'm a bandwagon fan man so
the whole summer I watch every NBA game
I have League Pass I'm on everyone's
Twitter I watch all the trade stuff
right really just so I know who to root
for you know so it's not like I'm
invested the way the you are I'm kind of
like which storylines exciting because I
like don't feel bad for millionaires
bandwagon a fan I just own it what a
bandwagon full so you know well I was
about to jump on and then boogie went
over to LA and I was like nah I think
I'm sticking with LeBron yeah you know
it's hard dogs I'm a huge LeBron James
fan how do you love Libra I love the
Bron James - I love everything about him
I love what he does I love his rise I
love like how he makes every place a
winner I love how people hate him and
how he comes back from that so I don't
know if Toronto could get a championship
I mean don't let the Clippers win a
championship it's gonna be hard I mean
but that Patrick Beverley and Kauai and
palter that is like insanely defensive
monster it's insane it's a you know
who's gonna get through that and plus I
just saw this stat Paul George and Kawhi
Leonard were in the top five of
efficiency
four players in the NBA last year like
when they have the ball in their hand do
so it's like come on it's a yeah but
it's gonna be terrible for comedy in LA
though you say that how do you think
everyone's gonna be at the game oh dude
or watching the games like I know when
the Lakers were good like doing like
that certainly right before the playoffs
whatever show was going on in LA
it's just ruined you know I've never
experienced that cuz the year I moved to
LA Lakers shock it was because I moved
in 2012 it was like right when I got
here like 2011 they were still making it
at 2012 they were like it was falling
apart at the seams so I've never been
here with a good la team it's terrible
it's you know it's like it's empty you
know you're like what's going on what's
Laker and now with the playoffs is gonna
be like dude Clippers Lakers so now we
got 82 games you know in LA it's unreal
82 games worth seeing yeah it's really
exciting even though I'm not a fan even
though I'm excited I'm not a fan of the
movement you don't you want people to
stay where they're at yeah I want it to
be like you know they're compensated
greatly to live in Minnesota Shh you
don't I mean this isn't 1972 you know
were they only make it a little bit of
money and then like no they make you
make if I'm giving you 30 million
dollars [ __ ] you live wherever
the [ __ ] I say you live also you can get
a green tea latte anywhere I mean that's
the truth you and you flying in the
offseason all these NBA players from
every team in the league live in LA you
know so it's like I just I don't think
that to me personally like so LeBron
James started the whole thing as I move
this move let's take power but he's not
qualified to run a fourteen billion
dollar business because that's what the
NBA is yet but you know a lot of these
teams are ruthless too though I mean
like did you see pressed he was gonna
trade Westbrook to Toronto he was just
ready to do it oh he was oh he was he
was ready to throw him in I mean that's
the guy that's like I'm Toronto I stayed
when Katie left they like start bullying
me I mean I'm okay see I see I'm gonna
trade him to try I'm gonna send him to
Toronto they were trying to what the
returns collided something hawai there
yes so they were gonna trade Paul George
and Westbrook over to Toronto they were
trying to get all Toronto's picks
through 2020 900 siakam I thought it was
gonna make more sense for them to be
like hey why don't you
you know since you want Paul George why
don't we send them to Toronto that's
well that's what they were trying to do
but they were gonna throw in Westbrook
and then they were gonna get siakam and
like all their picks for tenure Wow well
they got it they got a heist from the
Clippers though I know it's even better
deal than the Anthony Davis deal yeah
yeah eggs are nuts
well but they got those picks because
they traded Tobias Harris to the Sixers
yeah who got their picks from you know
all the [ __ ] that they had done over the
years yeah I mean so it's like I know I
love it's exciting right now but yeah
excuse me this is what we missed out on
okay so when LeBron was in Miami and
then they beat San Antonio mmm by the
way because the Kawhi Leonard missed a
free throw
like his free throw miss is why they
lost that championship because they were
up three if he would have won they
would've been up for they would have won
the championship then Ray Allen comes
down hits death three ties it up they
win the next game but anyway all right
so they go we're gonna run this back
mm-hmm and then they come back and they
beat Miami that was great mm-hmm that's
gone now you know yeah so uh Golden
State beats OKC I'm like this is gonna
be the rivalry of the ages this
[ __ ] goes to I will say though
all these guys now just signed some big
deals I think you're gonna have the next
three four years no one can go anywhere
you know I mean ad technically could I
think he'll resound with LA but you
could like everyone can kind of do like
everyone's gonna be in their spot and
and I think I mean we have Westbrook's
gonna be get traded he's on a big
contract though they were talking about
sending him to Miami which would be
insane oh you put my oh that's gonna be
great that might be the thing they're
like wow I would love that that would
make the East great Miami would
instantly vault into at least the top
five all right I know cuz once KD comes
back they still have some ballers if
he's no player in the history of the NBA
except for one player Dominique Wilkins
and even he wasn't a hundred percent has
come back from Achilles tear to be like
the player that they were I think to had
that with Wilkins was when he tore his
Achilles he was 23 23 to Saudi he's 30
or 31 yeah it's nice but
no he's not an explosive eclair anyways
a shooter so you might just end up being
like one of those like you know set shot
bill you know just you might be on some
like Dirk [ __ ] exactly obviously an
all-star the players in the league but
yeah I don't know I just I don't like to
move and I want to see like you know
build like I hope Milwaukee keeps the
Greek freak I hope that you know I mean
like they're already plotting maasai
taking him over to Toronto everyone's
like that's why I miss I didn't trade
siakam because he's gonna have prime
siakam and he's gonna get giannis to
come over every it's like fantasy
basketball all of a sudden that's why
I'm a bandwagon fan that's why I'm like
I don't feel bad for any of these
millionaires losing or moving or
whatever I'm just I'm in well you know I
started liking the Clippers back I used
to work at a grammar school this
Catholic school and one of the kids is
one of my it was like one of my favorite
players yeah I was a coach you know and
he like his mom worked at the Staples
not too stable said it was the Sports
Arena at the time he his mom worked at
the Sports Arena and then it was like he
goes hey coach you want to go to a game
mm-hmm and I was like what do you mean
he was like to the game so I get to the
game we got these great seats and I look
at him I go you just telling me this now
[Laughter]
like hell we do not come to these games
but then I just became a fan I used to
go to the clipper games all the time you
grew up in LA yeah cuz I would you grow
up I grew up in New Jersey New Jersey
okay so I wanted to go to I wanted to go
to the games cuz I was a fan of the
SuperSonics yeah so I wanted to go see
Gary Payton and Shawn Kemp yeah but then
after a while though you see you at the
fourth quarter you gotta support the
home team yeah I mean I'm supporting the
home team and then I'm like okay I
became a clipper fan dude were you a
nets fan Knicks fan which I was I was a
nets fan growing up that's what it was
like the great team is Jason Kidd Kenyon
Martin
then Kari kills they but Tumbo vitals
that was yeah that was like they were
crew and I was really into them but I
was also really into the Sixers I loved
Allen Iverson yeah he made me feel like
I could play cuz everyone's like oh hey
eyes short I think he was kind of like
the short kids a dream
that's what are we doing for kids right
now I mean well tall stuff though
we they just they in comparison to the
rest of to the rest of them I know well
that's what I had a teacher who was like
I would member telling my teacher in
eighth grade I was like I'm gonna play
in the NBA and he was like you're not
tall enough and I what are you talking
about Allen Iverson he's like how tall
is AI and I'm like he's six feet yeah
that's short for the NBA yeah short in
real life you're short in this class I
went to a like I went to a high school
where it was a small high school where I
was but one of the tallest people in the
school yeah at 6-3 muster thought you
were gone oh my god I went to big man
camp okay I remember I went to big man
camp and I was like what [ __ ]
everybody's a little man lumière bring
the ball up okay I'm a sinner too in my
school like brawny James have you seen
LeBron son I'm like watching highlights
of this like 14 year old and I'm like
this kid's gonna be unreal that's the
new world oh he's six he's six I don't
know he's he's like 511 no no he he's
he's getting up there he's getting up
there yeah he has his growth spurt
because they were like in high school
now him I think he went in nicely just
as he started going to high school he's
like teetering around six yeah I think
somewhere around six feet is insane I
know but he's gonna really he's gonna
shoot yeah yeah it's like but you know
if you think about it he's got like all
the best nutrition all the best like
trainer it's like like it sounds like
they'll make him talk even Dwyane Wade
kid yeah yeah there are yeah
Jack's get like a heart thing or
something but I think he's right he had
something [ __ ] he had like a thing he
had like sit out for a year but like
he's great he
I love watching those like there's like
YouTube channel that is all about that
yeah and then it's just like they show
like I'm like watching like highlights
of high school games and it's like but
it's like LeBron James is on the
sidelines and rip Hamilton's on the
sideline and their kids are like going
at each other I mean that's such a
fascinating time to live it feels
weirder the older I get because it used
to be like I looked up to these players
and and now I'm like cursing at someone
who's five years younger than me yeah
what are you talking about man but the
guy's my you know I know like everybody
that's my age that played NBA they've
all retired I'm the same age as Shaq
you know Namine so I'm like oh [ __ ] my
days are done you know it's like ah
maybe there was a time I thought you
look at them like oh these old retired
guys and you're like a year older and
now I'm the kid guy going like you don't
know how it was back you know I don't
know if you talked about this on here
but have you you saw Jordan play and you
saw the back yeah and LeBron I mean I
think that there's an argument that you
can make that LeBron is the greatest
player ever yeah I'm okay with that
argument that's the sign of how great he
is yeah but just like they like Max
Kellerman on ESPN says all the time the
advanced metrics they can measure all
these things yeah Jordan was better you
know what I mean at this point at its
height you know of his like dominance
you know and just like the eye test to
the guy was just fantastic and there's
just like a lot of things people don't
know about Jordan I there was that
stretch where their point guard was
injured and he played like 10 or 15
games where he was the point guard and
yeah averaged a triple-double yeah yeah
Kobe used to say that all the time
without what would have happened if you
were a point guard he would've been like
well I just would have been the best
point guard I guess I sorta have to have
been the best of that you know so I
don't know I mean I I'm a Michael Jordan
fan because I just look at all the
things he won six championships he beat
every Eastern Conference team in the
playoffs yeah at least once he be three
four different Western Conference teams
in the championship you know you know he
he beat like a bunch of top 50 players
of all
today he stops him from getting
Championships he was explosive and
exciting but there's an argument for
LeBron James you know he's 16 it's tough
because it's like Jordan there is the I
testing because you look at Jordan and
you watch them in the game like oh this
guy could kill whoever you like like
could murder to them like they murdered
them after the game there's different
tenacity and you watch LeBron and you're
kind of like oh you didn't do anything
this game and then you check the box
score and he had a triple-double it's
like like easily and it's it's so weird
but the thing about that is I think it's
just because he was you know cuz LeBron
so much better than everybody and it
looks so effortless for him yeah that
he's a victim of that yeah he don't got
to work as hard as everybody else but he
actually does yeah I always remember
that I think his game where he changed
his whole mentality was uh it was he was
they were down 3-2 to Boston
yeah in Miami mm-hmm and before the game
he had that I had a tiger look in his
eye I was looking at the screen I was
looking to get about to go off today
look and he had like 47 or whatever it
is they went on to beat them so it was
just like I don't know like I said if
you were somebody that came to me and
been like I think LeBrons better yeah
he's gonna have better numbers he's
gonna have better stats and all that he
won't have as many championships but
look at the error I mean I don't know a
whole different thing
yeah I think he's already accomplished
things that you can go like what after
greatest player ever sure you know I
mean so that's how I feel about uh feel
about that but I am excited about the
season I'm looking forward to the what's
gonna happen with the Clippers I mean I
really we're all excited he mean if you
take Toronto to the championship we're
feeling like okay that Denver still good
Denver stunned Dallas is gonna be good
porzingis is gonna be healthy with luca
Danka whatever the hell is there gonna
be good Minnesota still an up-and-coming
team they got to those young players
they're just they just don't have it in
their head but you guys Clippers to
Houston yes so I want I think the team
is gonna go away it's gonna be Oklahoma
City yeah they're gonna fall out there
they're gonna trade Westbrook New
Orleans is gonna hit that spot dude New
Orleans is excited I mean I'm excited
I've watched some early yesterday fat
though Diane I was watching a little bit
of that summer league yesterday it was
first I mean the earthquake was nuts in
the
middle that game I've never seen I mean
I was in a movie I was watching
spider-man oh no way I was in them I was
watching spider-man and the [ __ ] started
my friend my friend my was with he was
like he was like bro I think it's
earthquake it was like this you know and
I was like oh yeah they just kept going
and then everybody's panicking and I was
like oh this is the dangerous part yeah
like not even this speaker falling on my
head or whatever it's hi everybody
everyone right now so I was like Toma
from this we gotta sit tight for a
second yeah movie keep going
yeah the movie kept going it was such a
weird movie to such a weird tone you
know but uh yeah
where were you at the quake um I was
just a bunch of friends we were all
gather in an apartment and it was kind
of just like where are we gonna what are
we gonna do you know and um and so we
were strategizing just word is because
it was long enough that was kind of like
hey you get there you get I started
playing quarterback cuz people rose and
I was a keep get up move over get in
that corner like kind of you know grab a
pillow like that kind of thing oh yeah
but if you can do that it's not that
serious yeah I know
I don't know how do you I'm 28 you're 28
so that means you were like in 94 that
94 quake you weren't even here about
three years old or whatever like that
that [ __ ] was crazy right away instantly
I remember I was in my apartment butt
ass naked okay in like Koreatown I had
this little apartment in Koreatown my
place is a mess or a bachelor dude look
at this [ __ ] I'm I'm still a mess you
know I mean I don't by the way I want to
thank everyone for the art and stuff
look I put it up guys
you know this guy sent me this thing
we're from get lights up I just didn't
turn it on I got these great candles
beautiful cards I'm gonna get some
shelves but anyways so I'm you know my
place is messy and that [ __ ] was like it
was like immediately oh you know it was
like you would you knew you had to get
the [ __ ] out of the building okay are
you supposed to leave the building
listen man if you live on like the
eighth floor whatever it is like that
yeah
like your instincts are like is this
[ __ ] gonna fall over like so then it was
like but that didn't panic tokes I was
like get your pants you know yeah my
flashlight was yeah so I do suggest
everybody that that lives in California
that that [ __ ] just know where your
flashlight is or some candles or
something because that's the first thing
that goes to power was out you know but
what I'm saying is like it was a
rattling like you know like what you in
your mind what you think earthquake is
gonna be that was the worst earthquake
I've ever felt and I think that the
government lied to us
you know conspiracy theory time I go to
singing Mike conspiracy because I think
there's some kind of state law that if
we have an above like a 8 point
something earthquake I don't know this
is true in fact we searched for me fans
but I think there's something where we
don't pay taxes that year no way like we
don't pay like state tax or something to
help out with like there's something
right uh-huh
cuz they said that that quake that in 94
was a six point nine they just said they
just won over on what you call it was a
seven point what was a seven point one
no [ __ ] way that North Korea quake
yeah was a six anything yeah yeah that
[ __ ] was like but anyways if you can do
all that stuff where you're like okay I
don't know anything I was just and none
of us knew we're all like not from here
so we're like I mean I feel like in the
last seven years there's been little
ones but it made you go I know yeah
those oh it's like a really weak reason
to text an ex okay you good but it's
like you know she's fine like nothing
happened it's like a bonus Christmas
yeah because Christmas is when you go
hey what's up I was think you know Merry
Christmas ho well I just check on this
girl forgot to text people yesterday to
bone it man I should have like texted my
ex yesterday [ __ ]
you still texting now I know be like you
can say you can say you got caught up I
just got out yeah but I'll put it on
blast like this yeah yeah but this is a
good segue into cuz you were directing
your friends this is a good segue into
listen man
your show is fan TAS ah thanks fed no no
for real it is so good it's so like like
you're like the perfect like if I had to
like you know like you're a great
example of what woke should be like your
generation is like everybody thinks I'm
so woke to me woke is for people that
don't have the words to articulate their
position so they say I want to walk
right right right right you know you can
say walk for you know hey why'd you
pro-life yeah I'm woke yeah you know why
you pro-choice and woke everybody's woke
but then when you follow it up with the
things and I just think like the
perspective of being like a millennial
Muslim it's fantastic oh thank you
what's your like how did how did you
come about it like what was the we is
you always want to make a show like that
I always wanted to make something like I
remember like movie now and feeling this
you know I booked this show I moved to
LA because I was doing like this like
Nick at Nite sitcom I had a good time
doing it and then I remember you know
but I remember doing any kind of okay
this is just an acting job like what do
I really want to do yeah and I had felt
like I want to see some stories some
whether it be a movie whether it be a
show that had someone who felt like me
or who kind of like everything's always
really polarizing right it's like you
know [ __ ] God and [ __ ] religion and all
this stuff or the opposite of it it's
like it's super clean and it's like
super you know and and then if we touch
religion and so it's like the priest who
does coke you know or or it's like you
know this like the angels in heaven like
really blown out thing and so I knew I
wanted to make something that felt more
like the guilt and the way that I feel
about things and then kind of having
rattling around and you know how does
someone try to be good which sounds
really simple it sounds really basic but
I was like yeah that's kind of the thing
I want to do like how do you you know
you're trying to navigate being
person and I didn't know though if it'd
be like a show or a movie or whatever
yeah so when you say when you say like I
like how you say that when you're trying
to navigate to be good within the
parameters of like these expectations of
your family and religion and culture
yeah and also like your expectations on
yourself I mean like so much of it too
was like personal responsibility and
personal introspection and kind of like
how can you question you know what it is
that you believe and then what you
actually do because that was another
thing I really wanted to make something
that was like oh no this person actually
believes in being Muslim it's not like
forced on him by his parents cuz that's
how I never felt like my parents were
forcing it they taught me it but I
really you know felt a connection to it
but also you know you're drawn by your
desires and your ego and that clearly
conflict you know this thing that's
great you saying this cuz this in my
mind right now one of the like that's
what one of the great images of this
show for me hmm cuz like yes your
character I could tell he's like he's
excited about being Muslim ya know yeah
but at the same time he's [ __ ] this
white girl and checking the condom to
make sure there's no holes in it I mean
the cop that's just a great image like
what kind of Muslim is this guy I love
that that's the kind of stuff that went
through the whole show yeah and then I
love like you know it's like another
great moment it's like like you know
you're like trying to say all right I
don't want to go too far you're going
places but then you meet someone who
wants to go way far because the girls in
the car like that switch so that was the
conflict throughout the show right that
would you wanted to could you really
express that you expressed it well
that's what you were going for you did
it that's what was good yeah is that
like you know my friend Ali Amaro has
this book and about being she lives in
London and she has to spoke about being
a you know someone in a similar
situation and then she and she called it
the art of mastering schizophrenia where
she's like you know you you want to be
both things and you're kind of yeah
moving around and you're trying to
figure out you know what do I do what
what part of me is gonna come out and
and I think we all feel that on some
level it's not unique to be Muslim
but I wanted to put it through that lens
and I wanted to because that's what I
know right and and so that yeah that was
now you know follow-up question to that
then is it's funny how like we accept
things so do you find yourself even as
yourself going like okay so we're Muslim
and I have to accept all these things of
being Muslim but then you're living this
millennial life is there any part of you
that questions either or yeah yeah a
question both I mean that's kind of like
it's it's in you know there's stuff that
you question in the way that you were
raised with religion and you question
wait was that the culture was that the
actual faith and it's constantly this
like back-and-forth you know I know what
about the faith do I actually know so
even for me it's like okay cool so
there's you know how do I read the Quran
it's like oh I'm reading an English
translation it's a that's not the way
you're supposed to read it and so I've
gone down rabbit holes of like seeing
teachers and people who actually know
how to read this thing that it's cuz
it's kind of like a tools I would say
the same thing with the Bible same thing
with the door I mean these are books
that like need context you need to
understand cuz you can't take them word
for word right and that's not to say
that they're not there aren't accurate
things in there but it needs a
perspective like you need to kind of
understand what's going on with it and
you need it's it's a powerful tool it's
almost like getting anything in like you
need some training you know you need to
understand how do you get what's in this
and how do you get the truth out of it
and so I've gone down rabbit holes there
and then I'm also gotten on rabbit holes
of like moments where I've like been
like you know what let me just be in the
moment and let me just let me do what
I'm doing and I'm like this is the
moment like this is an insane moment I
don't this moment sucks I like I there's
just you know I remember one time going
out and you know you're trying to like
hang out whatever and I you ever go out
clubbing with Tehran I mean I was just
in Saudi with him may I need to find God
quick yeah no but I CI who I when I
watch your show and I Hugh you I
realized you really made a lot of
yourself in this character yeah ándale
right because it's like
because I'd noticed about the show is
this guy he really is questioning in the
in in trying to find like well how can I
be a better Muslim or finding more about
it you know what I mean and trying to
live that that that thing and I mean
that's such a hard that's such a hard
thing to like balance right yeah and I
mean and so much of it too is just like
trying to how do we do that in an honest
way how do we you know because for me I
was like okay I'm gonna bear a lot like
I want to just tell everything I kind of
want to put it out there in an
interesting way and there are things
that are dramatized and and of course
you know I mean it's better trained if
it's entertainment and and he's not a
comedian and like all these you know all
these things but yeah I was like how do
we do it where it doesn't feel cheesy
where it's not just like this like
preachy like I like you know think about
fate you know like I wanted to make it
feel as grounded and real as possible
and that's the stuff that we talked
about a bunch I mean you know re cater I
don't know I mean if you know him
through stand-up he made sure out show
them and so I always hear about Nick but
I never hear about yeah yeah yeah but
yeah I was like me re Ryan DRA I mean
when we first started talking about the
pilot that was so much of it with us
what we were just like alright how do we
like get these genuine things across but
like still have it sitting well I see
I'm a good draw one of my best friends
yeah you know I I just I love sitting
with him and talk to me saying such a
like you know you're you're you mean I
know but you're majorly influenced by
him I can tell right well sure I mean
with your special I was watching your
special I was like I was like oh man
this is like it's just very much like
this this sort of like vulnerable like
it's like we're not worried about we're
not gonna we're not gonna make like oh
we're not gonna worry about are we gonna
make this funny special like you know I
have to be funny funny funny yeah it's
more like just like I'm gonna like break
this down and I'm gonna express my
feeling about these things yeah yeah
that was fun I mean meeting him was
really cool cuz I like free I didn't
know him the first couple years I was
here but I would always like people
would meet me me yeah oh dude you gotta
meet your I feel like you guys get along
oh man you guys are like on some
wavelength together yeah you guys were
really and and and I remember even like
friends of mine who would like seen his
special is the first one they're like oh
wait do you know this dude you guys are
like and we always kind of
was just kind of like kinder like you
guys got a hang you guys gotta this and
then jamming out with him and being like
oh wait like we really are on the same
side I mean I think there's a lot of
like approaches where we really diverge
and I mean rods very like he kind of I
mean I loved watching him but he like
attacks and audience in a way I've never
seen anyone like you don't want to do it
different I watch him do stand-up and
watch people leave cry like a little boy
being at the improv once and just seeing
so much get up emotionally it's just so
attack and I remember like I well I'm
not there's not that but ya know we both
like had like an aversion to you know
anything that felt too removed from who
we are I mean for me that's on screen
that's on stage or it's like I'm not
good at act outs that's why I don't do
them like I'm not like I don't know how
it happened that's not your thing it's
just not my thing like I don't know how
to tap into it so that's something that
we definitely like jammed out so I'm
very aware that because it's like we
it's kind of why we became friends we
connected on that well on the show I
mean there was the the stylistically I
look I love the show because there's do
you think there's three episodes I
really enjoyed because of this it's like
one that was all about the mom yeah yeah
you know because it was like is she
gonna cheat yeah or did she just enjoy
the attention and it was like that was
great and then one about the sister yeah
you know I mean Mike my ex-girlfriends
Jewish so and it was like very much I
read an article where somebody was
saying if you're Muslim or if you're
Jewish you need to watch this show yeah
that fan because it's the same kind of
family experience you know I mean um yes
but anyways I really did enjoy that that
stylistic choice so the the mom episode
the the daughter episode yeah and then
the episode of the young Rami yeah you
know just like you know trying to fit
trying to figure out masturbating and
like you know all of that stuff was
greater than the 9/11 stuff and you too
you do talk about it in your specialty
I'm just being like you know that how
this affected you know you yes yeah yeah
no I mean it's those episodes are some
of my favorites too I mean they're
they're so they're so we get to like get
really specific
like you know different perspectives
yeah I mean it's been great the
reception that those have gotten and
then I'm yeah they're great episodes you
know and they're also the ones I'm not
in so you're like oh wow that's really
when the show shines you're very
vulnerable as an actor but I really I
enjoy it was a director too
it really excited excites me when people
like those because it's like it's like
we built this tone and then it kind of
can expand into anything I think that's
what's so exciting about them is that
like it the tone lets it kind of like
breathe for all the characters which was
something I was really excited about
doing when we when we set into it well
you know that's the thing too is that
it's not just those standalone episodes
it's the fact that within the framework
of your 10 episode show you decided to
these things were important for the
overall story yeah I mean so it's like
I'm interested to see what would happen
for us is their season - yeah yeah we're
in the writers room oh that's great
because I'm interested to see how season
2 is gonna come about because now all
your stories are done yeah you know I
mean yes it's like oh that was my kid
and then this is the 911 in the walkie
talkie yes all that stuff now it's like
now what you know so now I'm interested
to see where you go that this is more
challenging actually I've season two is
way more challenging so but I look
forward to see what you're going and I
do and I'm hearing a me buzz I'm hearing
those kind of things I know it's like I
know you don't don't [ __ ] be humble
over there no no I'm not even gonna be
humble I would be I would I would bother
me if we didn't get nominated for one oh
for sure no it would I feel like you
know we deserve to be part of the
conversation yes at least it was a
nomination that being said I'm super
realistic and it's like it's not it
genuinely isn't why I do it
the reason it would bother me is because
it's really good exposure for the show
like I think that in this the bubble I'm
in I feel like a lot of people are
seeing the show but you know in a really
wide way it still hasn't you know it
slipped through in a really cool way
it's cracked yeah I think people are
watching but like I would love to get
nominated so that more people watch it
so so it's you know that would be great
well the more you get out there what's
great about it is where it lives people
can still find people will find it yeah
they'll be like oh let's go oh that show
oh let me go check that out cuz I tell
everybody all that
I had a meeting with somebody - the
other day I was talking about you know
for pitching something in and the guy
was talking about in the pitch in an
innocent meeting he's saying like well
we want to do I want to do things like
what Rami Yousef on he was you know
about like let's have an episode about a
different character so that's like I
said to myself in that meeting I thought
I'll he's coming on my podcast I can't
wait to tell him this you know that's
what you know you're making a difference
so that's really exciting
yeah that's really exciting so then you
know you went to Egypt to film that huh
yeah yeah we spent the last two episodes
there so I was there for like a month
oh the bull doze the whole place I'm
just gonna be honest okay just I just
gonna be honest with you dude I Louis
your home country and all that but that
[ __ ] needs to be bulldozed and
start over okay there's just too many
people man they don't got the
infrastructure I was on a freeway okay
we're on a bus we're on a freeway we're
behind a bus the bus stops in the middle
of the freeway and lets out a whole
family with three goats I was like I'm
out okay I'm out
a whole family is on a motorcycle you
know to me well I mean that's yeah
that's you you you take the an extended
family on one motorcycle lot of walking
yeah I mean bulldoze it all and start
over such an LA mentality man I love
that country
I could tell it's I really do I go every
year it's amazing it's complicated it's
messy it's sweaty it's beautiful it's
it's really creative like I don't know
how you if you felt like the creative
inspiration there I I really like I felt
were you doing shows I was doing shows
there I've gone a couple times because
of him you know yeah and it was like it
was very interesting experience you know
they think I'm Egyptian you know like my
face about it you know I was like okay
I genuinely a you look an Egyptian and
they're probably pissed that you didn't
learn Arabic they're like what the you
lost your culture over there in America
but I had all these jokes that I was
like you know I was nervous and I
remember saying to a meadow say gee you
want me to do these you know the jokes
I'm gonna do right he was like do it do
it glad to do it and it was just like a
great response you know I mean I went to
the pyramid I went to like you know
which I was really disappointed like how
dirty it was cocaine the pyramids and
then you like look left to what you know
is never in the photo TGI Fridays that's
always that's always a big shock by the
way but not to interrupt you but I want
it because I want you to talk about this
while you whatever you're about to say
to is that yeah I could tell how excited
you were to film in Egypt really like it
came across on the screen like yes my
first thought when I saw that I was like
oh [ __ ] they're actually they're
actually and I was like this must have
been so fantastic to film in Egypt like
well how did that come about it was I
mean you know so much of it for me
making the show was like okay let's say
we only get one season right like that
that's you know kind of going and being
like I'm not gonna I'm not gonna save
this for you know season 2 or 3 it's
like man we had 10 episodes like I want
to use every idea I've ever had and I
want to make it amazing and I want to
put it all out on the table I mean even
like the the walkie talkie episode
that's based on the thing for my
stand-up that's I mean that I had kind
of treated out as a movie at some point
and watch it you're like oh yeah this
could be a movie ya know I don't care
how do I know I'm gonna get to make a
movie call it a Muslim thing yeah easily
you see I love that whole it that's you
know a lot of these things could have
been in different I was like no I want
to do everything and then I know how to
do it you know I know that it can be in
the integrity of the character and we
talked a lot about as a writers room and
you know with with my producing team
everyone we were just like how do we
pull off all these things we really want
to do is so I chipped was so on the list
it was like we
do this we have and and it was I was so
excited I mean it I went there I was a
kid I still go as an adult and to go
there and get to work there and work
with an all Egyptian crew - Wow and they
were so dude they were so excited to
make this yeah yeah everyone was so
pumped so supportive I would have loved
if you would have just looked at camera
one time we're in Egypt also the
attitude of like getting things done
there is really exciting I mean
everyone's just excited and wants to
make something happen like we you know I
remember we were shooting a scene and it
was like this montage and and I was like
oh man we've been cool if we had like a
kid for this thing you know for this bit
and then the production managers goes
what kind of kid it's a lawless country
so you could just grab a kid in 10
minutes you have three moms and like
pick pick up my you know like put him in
and yeah and what here that would take a
week he's gotta go do school like as if
like acting like like acting kids on set
actually get real school but I loved the
whole going to Egypt on the show was
like so authentic it was like you had to
bring six suitcases bring the iPads and
you have to like you know everybody you
have to bring four uncle and Auntie you
know this kind of stuff and I'm like cuz
my family's from Belize mmm so it was
like that when I was a kid you know he
was like oh you have to take all this
stuff and you had yet to take like you
know ensure and like anyone who has
family anywhere else knows that whole
your bags are being packed for you I
mean I almost wanted to shoot the scene
at the airport where the guys like did
you pack these bags yourself or the on
the forum I think it was great man and
my one of my favorite parts about that
and by the way guys you really should
watch this show it's on Hulu but you
know cuz I know we're talking about you
a question
about it's just called Rami and it's on
Hulu
but one of the parts that I really
enjoyed in the Egypt is that you're this
American guy and you're Muslim you woke
yeah and you're like talking about like
Oh guys you guys did it you were in the
streets for the you know you guys were
you know and then they like put you in
your place like yellow broke people died
yeah
like like like stop we don't want to
talk about this yeah and I was like good
for you
I mean was so much of it was just like
how do we call out my character and that
happens in every you know every episode
it's like I didn't want to make a
character that it was just you know this
perfect guy who does the way it's like
no he's very flawed he's a flawed he's
got and he shows up to Egypt and he's
like you know questioning people about
the Egyptian revolution it's this
amazing historical thing that you know
he's so excited to learn more about and
everyone's like dude it's still
happening wait what are you like like
can you stop snapping on this nerve you
know and and and really kind of like we
because it was so interesting to me is
like the way we stereotype ourselves you
know we think that we you know kind of
uh oh well I'm the thing so but no it's
like two year you can be racist against
your own people you can be ignorant
towards all those things and and so
we're kind of trying to strip away at
that you know strip away at this like
this fabricated idea of self you know
and and and you really get to it and so
that those episodes really fun to strip
a lot of that back it was good man and
another thing I really enjoyed about to
show is the your friend yeah the guy
whoever that guy is great man he's
almost show that would be like if you
really if liberal really really wants to
go all the way are you working on it oh
okay great
he's like what does he have what is that
he is muscular dystrophy he has muscular
dystrophy yeah and he's like now did you
have a friend like that is it based off
someone real it's him I've known him
since their days
[Music]
fan yeah that your that's why you guys
had great chemistry it was just like
good fantastic again one of my favorite
scenes is like you I was like what a
like relationship you know and then
that's why I thought it was important
for you to show that episode as a kid
yeah met and this is how long they've
known each other and then you're just
like oh that's why he's wiping his ass
he's like it's brother need known each
other further their whole life but he's
great
he's amazing he's he's such a such a
highlight I mean it was so cool to like
you know he's also a really good
stand-up and it's great he's really
because his voice is so clear like he
knows what he don't know what they're
talking about it's not right and and and
you know it seems self-aware yeah and
it's so interesting because it's like
hard for him to do stay I mean lucky if
he's in New Jersey I mean New York
comedy clubs if you have you know I
don't even if you're a if you're
able-bodied you can barely get it you
could probably barely get down these
like naraba going down then I think
about yeah I might get an injury trying
to club and so he's not someone who's
like out there on the circuit getting a
ton of exposure we're making this show
he hasn't been in a ton of stuff I know
he can act yeah he's a bit in anything
but I know he can and so we're writing
this character and then you know we come
to casting and who was kind of all right
cool so like who's gonna play Steve and
I'm like Steve Steve Steve's gonna play
steam you're like what what's he been in
nothing and then we do the audition and
then they were just like oh that's good
I would love to I would love to have I
would love to see watch Steve do so it's
something that I'm really excited yeah
he's like a store manager or something I
don't know just like I just did you drop
him anywhere how people have to interact
with him you know I need to be on that
show put it out here that's good so he
was great too man
and then that let's go into like again I
I watched your special and again it was
it's just like it's a different style
that I'm used to
yeah yeah so I'm just being honest you
know
different style and I'm just like I'm
trying it's like having these deep
conversations with Jerrod all the time
sure what stand I'm supposed to be being
I think so that's why I say I very much
like enjoyed watching like that
influence not necessarily his influence
like him but I'm saying the influence of
being like hey let's do this different
sure sure
yeah yeah and you definitely were I mean
especially what you ended it I mean
great way to call back on that joke to
like just like just to say the words did
not work yeah yeah a lot more context
that's why you have to watch a special
just on HBO called feelings but you set
up this just the way you set everything
up and just like how you talked about
the things what were you satisfied with
were you satisfied that you got out
everything you wanted to get out yeah
you know how it is like you've done a
couple specials right I mean it's like
you kind of get your but I want to scrap
them all when I watch you young guys I
can see what you guys are doing just
like what am i doing I mean I mean you
know a lot of the show is from that
material right like you can see kind of
a lot of that stuff like ended up being
the backbone for most of the episode I
saw a lot of the dialogue is like you
know stuff from onstage and so there was
this relationship with as I was working
on the show I'd be on stage kind of
working things out and and you know I
mean it's how we pitched the show I
didn't we did have a script we had like
45 minutes of what is part of what is
now feelings oh sweet and then and then
you know I probably scrapped like 15 of
it wrote a different 30 and kind of like
piece that together to make the special
right but it was really it's really cool
I mean it's like it's it's really fun to
have it out there at the same time as
the show yeah I think they're the it
feeds the conversation like back and
forth between it and you know how it is
it's like we're always perfectionist
it's like the second you're done with it
and you know that like all I forgot that
bit and you're like oh man and that
other tag and that other thing
the thing I'm most happy about with it
is it feels like me like and it feels
like it feels like like I think if
anyone came out to watch my hour while I
was working it it would have felt like
that night you know Anna and I like that
Anna and I felt like okay so that's me
like I don't feel like I'm you know
something else or someone else and and I
don't feel you know sometimes there's
this energy of like this is this the the
stand-up special version of me or
something it's just like it's just like
this is the off the cuff you know it's
like it's it's that and and and so that
was kind of my attitude going in and and
I was really happy that that that you
know showed and so I was just watching
it I was like okay cool that's like I
own that shirt you know like sometimes
you see like you sometimes you see
someone like get up on like and you're
like I has you know I you talk about the
reward that outfit
that's something me and Jerrod and and
bo burnham had talked about a bunch of
just like clothes like clothing we were
like just weird like I know this dude I
know this dude he doesn't own those
shoes whenever we get those shoes and so
but and that's not like I love comedy I
love stamp I think that everyone's
specials that I've seen were they're
influential on me so I think it's
constantly every everyone's kind of like
bouncing off of like different things
but I think when you look at the
material you look at the whatever you
know you're like so so what is this
person's like bringing to this that I
haven't seen and for me I was like okay
I'm seeing some stuff that I had wanted
to say and I didn't feel like was being
said and that's what's most satisfying
to me about it that's how I feel about
the show and this and that too you know
our show like people be like oh it's in
the vein of Atlanta vein of Louisiana
this video that everyone's always gonna
look at like the reference point of the
thing that's kind of in the blah blah
yeah what can I kind of like put it to
words you know what can I kind of like
angle it with and so but then you like
digging like okay cool so what's fresh
here what's new you know and and I think
most stand-up specials are similar in a
way that doesn't bother me really
because it's like well what's the person
saying because that's what it all ends
up being we were actually saying into
the microphone and what new thoughts are
you putting out there and I felt like
there were a lot of things I wanted to
say that I'm very happy I got to say it
I'm very happy get to be out there and
so yeah so that's that makes me happy
that's good man yeah I could tell I mean
you look you look happy and content like
you just
to attack more but what do you what do
you what do you think about the state of
stand-up comedy right now um I mean it's
in a good place
I don't know I I can't tell I mean I you
know it's funny because you kind of
started off talking about the the woke
situation in a way and I think it's like
you know with everything I just said you
know obviously I have there's sincerity
to what I want to do but it also has to
like you have to kind of embrace what
could I say here that can't be said not
here right so like let's like we get the
the safety of telling jokes in a way
like that should feel safe because that
means we can get really [ __ ] up and
that means like we can go to places that
we shouldn't go to which is something we
can't see tried to do on the show is
something I try to do in stand-up where
it's like okay my job is to like go into
these really like even we talked about
the ending of the special like there are
certain things in that special that like
I wouldn't drop in a convo go on this
journey the yeah you get where we're
going with it
look I think there's a problem if your
stand-up set could play on CNN like I
mean and that's like like United me like
I don't you know and now I will exclude
Colin Quinn because it Colin Quinn made
his thing and and it's really good
because it's like crafted for a certain
thing but it's like I think it should
have like edge you know like if you were
on CNN yeah and they wanted to they
can't really quite yes what can we play
from here which I felt that way when we
were like doing the you know the circuit
I'm like okay cool okay I'm happy like
I'm happy this is this kind of it and
it's not sensational or dirty just for
the sake of being but it's like it's
like stepping into like it should be an
honest expression that doesn't make the
comedian per se look good I don't think
like I think there's a subside of things
why that's that's like really if we talk
about the state of stand-up that's
something that's really tough to watch
I'm just like it's like you're watching
people kind of defend themselves and I
think it's more interesting to further
position defend their position defend
their positions defend who they are kind
of be on the right side and it's like
okay be on the
side but also show how you're wrong
while you're on the right side like
that's more interesting to me it's like
it's like like what what's like ugly
about you is really nice and that's
something that like I have found as I've
been doing it doing the show helped a
lot
those are I mean obviously conversations
I've had with comics that I really
respect like I've talked to like had
Campos obviously like drew I don't know
if you're gotten drew Michael on the
east great he's so drew so thoughtful no
no talk for an hour about his you know
no audience special I love going back
and forth with him about it and then I
said like that's a whole that's a whole
Jerrod thing you know they they did this
[ __ ] you know and they just the
way they talk about it it's like shad AB
you pretentious [ __ ] you know but
that's just part of this part of this
movement and so by the way I want to
just because I never got to actually
make my point and now that I think about
that you mention it well cuz when I say
when people say they woke they don't
necessarily follow it up with anything
and what I'm saying is what I've noticed
with you is with your sho with your
special you're following up your state
of being of who you are
mm-hmm and so then you're expressing
that and I think it's an important thing
to watch you know whether you dig it or
not you know yeah I mean I think it's
like I don't think I've never felt like
I always did any time watching someone
or something where they were being them
you know in an honest way where I'm like
okay cool like I I saw something right
now is that my person is that the person
I vibe with it doesn't really matter I
mean like I think there are really good
things that are like you know 50% Ron
tomatoes because they really split
people you know I to me where it's just
kind of like oh man you want to be like
you wanted to be like oh I can't believe
you said that
yeah there are different 50% rotten
tomatoes there are some words like oh
that [ __ ] just sucks and then there's
some where it's like oh no that just
that's for some people and it's not for
other people and and I think that that's
good like I think that that's an
exciting thing and and kind of with you
know I don't know where do you think
stand-ups at I mean are you excited
because I just think it's weird I think
it's oversaturated I think that the
people aren't people aren't experiencing
you know the live performance they not
you know that's really what stand-up is
yeah because it's not like music but
that's what we're compared to you know
instead it's like somebody has an an
album and then we like that sound and
then we go watch them live it's actually
the reverse for stand-up but then people
are skipping the live element right
they're skipping it and they're just
trying to get to the snippet the little
TV version the little 15-minute Netflix
or the you know all these things and
it's just like that's not really because
how many great stand-ups
do you know like we have friends trim
and they've done half hours and then you
go mmm what happened there and they're
so good but after doing a half-hour
myself yeah experiencing how it happens
I go I totally get why people tank or
yeah cuz the way they said they set you
up for failure
yeah so that's not the same as like when
you just go see somebody raw at a club
and get that experience that's real
that's the standard a really admire I
don't I think that's I don't think that
that is well go ahead what I say I gotta
say this is not just cuz I'm here this
is something I've said off the record
various time off the record everybody
various times off the record would rummy
I've said this off the record various
times you're probably one of the few
people that like when you're up killing
and if I'm up next I'm like and that's
not I don't forget it I don't feel that
way about a lot of it no but like you
wouldn't you kill you tell me more mommy
ya know like when you go in I'm just
like oh my god this is I've also seen
you like isolate a crowd to like I've
seen you like Butthead it's amazing it's
like but like you try to do it when you
do it you like just like that's the
energy I really like what I'm saying but
I think that that's what people see what
I my point I'm trying to make is go
watch people live yeah cuz you're gonna
you're gonna see something yeah they
like you go whoa I didn't expect that
tonight or you you might catch me on a
night where I'm in a good mood and I'm
oh you might catch me in that run like
you know what [ __ ] everybody and but
that is an experience yeah you know and
it's like it's not just this like you
know cookie cutters put together in a
way that is presented like tada not
everything has to be like that and I
just think there's just a lot of that
right now we're
I don't know I I think stand up to the I
think I'm just 50/50 about it I think
part of me says wow look how much is out
there the other part of me is like I
wish there was some wish it was better
content out there ya know it's it's
there's a lot of set I mean like
obviously the with the Netflix of it
where it's just like there's a lot it's
just a lot there's a ton like anyone
who's pretty good should have one like
it's like an it's got it's almost like
if you're good and you don't have like
Byron Allen show remember that late
night show that everybody did know what
was the name of it oh god laughs no no
no no but the round table where he's
like you know he's doing like a somewhat
interview so so Robbie I heard you went
to Egypt then you do your Egypt joke oh
man but anyway that's what it's in yeah
I know what you're saying is like if you
good or am I good or just like
expectation at one out I mean like for
me
the timing of doing this special was
really like I really wanted to do it
with the show because I do think that
they kind of like they feed off each
other and the most important thing to me
was just like you know I want to
introduce people to how I think I
obviously wanted to be funny like it has
to be funny you can't just like making
points that's the balance though right
that is the heart especially with
especially with your style yeah sure she
was your style how you talk about the
coop of people that you hang around with
sure Jerrod and Beau and these type of
people they are very much like I'm gonna
I need to say this sure sure yeah yeah
yeah but the skill as a stand-up is to
say that yeah and also make it funny
yeah and I think that like it's it's
that's where it's gonna come down to
preference right because it's like I do
think I think I feel like everything I
said in my special always hit a punch
but I do think that there are people who
might watch it and just be like man this
dude's just like slow or something but
they might watch and be like man [ __ ]
this [ __ ] and I'm okay with like that's
fine that's fine it's kind of like okay
cool like that's like cool that's what
you yeah that's the but that's the whole
point of putting something out it's like
right you are and of course you're
entitled to that opinion I asked you to
watch me for 56 minutes that's [ __ ]
nuts you should only watch me for 56
minutes if you love it and if you don't
then that's good to like like move
but that was the old-school way would be
like you would build up an audience and
then a special is was this is just like
you know for your fans to be like hey
Here I am
yeah you know but now it's like it's
different now we're introducing people
with special sure I mean I I had a weird
thing where it's like my show came out
before my special that's nuts
yeah show called Rami and it's a who's
Ramat it's like it's like a weird I mean
that's part of the streaming and that's
part of like the way things are and so
I'm so aware of like how out of order
that might be and so and and but it's
but it's kind of like out of order but
like out of order dude like with the
traditional kind of trajectory and it
out of order isn't even bad like that if
it's bad I'm just kind of like looking
at it and I'm like okay cool so this is
like this and that and then you figure
you're figuring out the format too
so for me it's like I watch my show 10
episodes and I'm kinda like okay cool I
know how I'm gonna make that better and
then I watched my special and I'm like
oh cool I know I'm gonna do the next one
and you kind of like grow well what's
great about it tuza
you know now that Netflix stole comedy
from everyone yeah so now when you do it
on these other networks they actually
are special yeah yeah HBO can they
should coined it like you know no
because remember it used to be like all
you got to get HBO special yeah I feel
special now it's yeah I understand the
power of Netflix I get it I mean I'm
sandler movie and it was like everybody
that's ever met me it's like hitting me
up like yo man I'm watching your movie
it sounds unreal so but that's
necessarily make it this is the power of
Netflix I've had people with the show
and with the special tell me dude I love
your Netflix show and oh man dude your
Netflix special is so good it's like
dude it's like I say this all the time
it's like Kleenex they have they have
coined like where it's like oh you are
you watching that Netflix show and it's
like this is the WB man what do you not
like reading tweets that I like yo this
this Netflix show Romney goes hard yeah
and I'm like would you yeah you just got
sorry Hulu why Hulu were they the ones
who said yes
we I get it nothing for that we were we
were very very fortunate mean you know
you got pitch you pitch a pitch we
pitched like six seven spots we had
three offers which was great it was
really tough actually were between FX
and Hulu and and and it was it was
really why'd you choose Hulu between the
two yeah me an to me I'm glad you picked
I just can i yeah about it first just
see my thoughts is that if you go on
Hulu you don't got a whole back anything
yeah and just in case you need to say
and do things the things you show them
in your show were important for the
story and FX might have been like you
can't have a condom full of [ __ ] on the
screen I don't know I mean it's it's
hard to say I don't know I just made no
no no yeah I mean cuz they they take a
lot of it I mean they do is I mean
that's the place right yeah watched a
few times he did he did a lot no it was
I mean they do a lot it was really cool
I it was more just like I'm no one you
know and and it's kind of it's so hard
to go through the pilot process and so
you're kind of like what's the place
that like has nothing and needs it more
I mean we made the deal with Hulu
handmade still wasn't even out yet oh
really that's when we made our deal and
were like they were like we got this
show coming out it's gonna be better
than Game of Thrones and I'm like they
didn't say better they said it's gonna
be our game of thrones and then I watch
it and I was like oh my god this is it
was like that sounds like that's true
hey Misa yeah yeah I haven't seen the
new season I watched the first two I was
like yo this is I gotta catch up that's
that show is ill I watched as a dude
when I watched that show I'm always like
like I always think to myself how how if
this happened if that happened where
would I land yeah I have to really sit
and ask myself like where would I land
likes it because it makes you think
should I be doing more in this society
[Music]
you know what I mean it's like you just
go like but my favorite scenes in that
show is like you know cuz the girl the
lady what's her name mrs. Waterford you
know yeah
she's like was part of making this all
thing yeah she's got her little notes
they come out and go yeah they're not
gonna let you speak you know and she was
like oh you know doubt that was the
moment you know and then she walks away
and the guys all like yeah they forgot
their way they forgotten their way in
their place and I was like yeah hits you
in the core you know and I think that
you you're right on message with who if
that's what who's trying to do it's like
make it yeah ground breaking they're
they're going for it they you're going
for it your show is a good go for it I
just feel like you guys out there if you
are ethnic at all I think you should
watch Romney's show because you know you
just really you know you learn about
yourself because as an audience member
watching like I'm going through your
eyes then at the same time you know I'm
watching the show and I'm going oh man
don't do that what you do and that's why
I love your to friends in the show too
let's give them some love yeah those two
guys are great because they are so
grounded
in like like what you think you want to
be and that's what's so funny about it
is that they're who you should be trying
to be like they're married they got jobs
funny man you know yeah dave Marez I
mean he's I don't you seen him do
stand-up
he's unreal I started following them
because of the show and Moe have you not
seen moe moe is so cozy yeah he's got a
Netflix but they both have Netflix
specials out and they're just they're
killers man and it was really cool
because they've you know I've lived with
both of them at certain times oh really
and so there's that chemistry and it's
just a fun dude it was great it was its
props to them they really make it feel
alive I mean it's yeah they really they
really do make it feel alive and wait oh
but just to close the loop on this like
this decision thing was you need to sing
[Music]
everybody likes this [ __ ] mine was
thinking on it Yemen it was it was just
a good when we were picking how we
wanted to do it it was you know it's
just a choice between where you think
you got the best shot and and it's and
and it's such a slim window yeah you
have so much respect for all the places
I mean cuz everyone's like all these
networks you gonna pitch to all of me
like just amazing things and you're kind
of like I want to be part of all that
and and and so for me it was just at the
time again it's not like there was
anything going on and Hulu that you were
like you gotta be there but I just felt
like it I could make it I was like oh
cool like this might get through on your
first thing you're always let me do this
yeah can I just do it in the pitch
process and everything did you already
did you already let them know hey I
think we're gonna go film in Egypt or
when did you drop that on him I cuz that
was probably a like the cost was
probably like you know this is the crazy
thing say they probably wish they could
shoot all of it in Egypt oh go to Brazil
I'm not resilient and they're like for
half so no they were it was it did come
up in the pitch yeah it was it was part
of the pitch well that's how he sold the
whole thing it was part of it
yeah you and your look and everything
like that everything mmm he's an
adorable terrorist let's do this I don't
know does that does that leave room for
with all your busyness is it leave room
for romance oh man dude what do you do
you you got something going I did but
I'm single now I'm single now yeah I was
in a relationship for you know almost
almost two years because I'm always
curious how people are balancing it with
standards balance yeah it takes a it
takes a rare I I commend my
ex-girlfriend cuz like to put up with me
and my personality it's a lot guy
especially like you know cuz she was
beautiful and like you know and then
beautiful women they love getting
attention
sure and when you're in the
entertainment business
like I'm gonna get all the attention you
know so she said to me oh this was great
I was I was I took her to the queer at
the Comedy Store and Brad Williams is
there with his wife Elia you know and oh
no she wasn't with me and I'm telling
his wife is like where's your girlfriend
I was like I'll bring her she was like
yes she's sick at home we have a support
group for you know you know and then I
told my girlfriend about it she was like
oh that's great I do need to talk to
someone about how do they deal with the
track this one she said how do they deal
with the travel and the diva behavior of
course I'm a diva yeah of course of
course so it's like you can barely deal
with your own like you must be
unbearable right now unbearable I don't
I don't want to put her on blast yeah
I'm seeing someone but she you know oh
it's just you win the scene I guess
that's what you say I figure they're
seeing someone right now i think i think
it's called date by guest a young people
call it seeing i'm goin steady let's
take it back to like i'm going steady
with a gal oh that's good daddy with a
gal and they it's like a hard balance i
mean it's cool now cuz i'm like i'm here
i'm just writing like this everything's
had died down there was a time when
you're gonna be like hey i'm going on
this world tour the cam leaving for six
months yeah yeah yeah we're gonna have
to figure out weekend's and it's like i
think you know it's like i feel
optimistic about it it's not forever
that she'll look back on this after you
break up with her and be like remember
when you love to me how quickly do you
say i love you yeah oh man that's a
toughy in a relationship you know what I
think you say it when you don't mean it
yet hmm
but you feel like it's like you're like
it's like you're on the roller coaster
yeah yeah yeah you're already in the
seat you started going and you're at
that you're going and you go you know
it's there I see it so let me just let
me just say this and you've got to hope
that when you move that you feel that
feeling you're like I actually do mean
this
cuz that's when you really when you say
ìlook to me when you say I love you
it's not because you love them you know
right but it's after you've already said
I love you and then you're in it and you
have a moment where you go WOW oh yeah I
really do love you yeah that's when it's
there
yeah and you're there yet that's great
man and then you know you're like it
will be undisclosed y'all look different
with a little bit of sunlight and
there's no need that's when Republicans
say that when they find out their kids
are gay that's when they go we're all
the same are we all human beings just
body parts yeah well that's good man I'm
glad I'm glad that that's happening but
this is you're right in season two and
that's gonna when you start shooting
that researching that in October
yeah also you just over in New York and
you're just moving and grooving are you
still filming in New York yeah Wow okay
I guess you have to yes
it's just we gotta grab it and hopefully
we shoot more in Jersey this year and
we're trying to like make a couple yeah
just a couple cool episodes that are
definitely gonna need us to be over
there wow I would love to see the
episode just about one of your friends
yeah yeah we've been talking about it
one of them because that's how you do
the spin-off you know yeah that's how
the Jeffersons was you know yeah so what
else you watching what she what's your
what's your what's your jam right now
you are you you find time for TV I've
been trying to get stuff like I kind of
go back and forth between I feel like
there's always two mentalities and
making something where you're like okay
let me watch everything you know what
there or I want to watch nothing because
I can't anything to see I mean when I
was doing my special I didn't watch any
standup like I don't think I watched I
don't think I watched anyone special for
like two years there's like I really
don't think I watched like like I would
kind of peek in see what people are
doing this and that you watch a little
bit and you're like oh man [ __ ] I
love Nate bargatze but like I'm only
gonna watch seven minutes of this
because I don't want to like you know I
don't want it to seep into - I'm doing
well probably the only ones I watched or
maybe like Chappelle just cuz you're
kind of like oh I mean that's just my
favorite so I was like yeah but then you
watch this is what happens the seeds see
I feel like you have to watch these
things sometimes just because you want
to find out am i talking about the same
stuff I don't care okay see my thing is
like doesn't in my mind I'm like I'm
like because I try to put everything
through a barometer of only I could say
it
that's something I'm proud about with my
special I don't know what joke of mine
you could lift because it's all kinda
tied to Who I am and it's all kind of
tied to like right what I you know like
like that's how I like so so for me it's
like it doesn't matter if we're talking
about the same thing because Eric's
version is gonna be so much different
yes so it's like I kind of don't give a
[ __ ] yeah that's that's been well it was
like I did like man it was like you do
you know you do there's to me there's
just too much comedy out and not enough
of it is like at its highest quality
sure because it's just you just doing it
let me just get it out yeah so then now
there's more people there's more
recorded stand-up of people talking
about the same [ __ ] sure you know that's
just that that's just how we what the
state of what we live right now yeah so
because even with Chappelle's special I
would have loved for him to combine all
for those one really fantastic special
yeah but you know it's like he did
they're just like if you giving people
listening you give me twenty million
dollars I'm coming out with dude I don't
care how you know I'm doing them I'm
gonna be like different races you know
you get up there part of six minutes of
your special is you taking the call from
Pauly Shore
go you called me bro it's probably gonna
be a bit in someone special one of these
you know like a phone call my mom's
always calling me Mom it's my special no
no no it's not not only is it not only
your jokes on shows on specials they're
also on podcast now so you can't watch
anything
so you weren't watching any comedy you
weren't watching I really yeah I mean
right now I just on TV I saw I'm getting
through fleabags season two which I
don't know if you've seen that [ __ ] no I
haven't seen what what's that on it's on
Amazon Prime but it's it plays in the UK
I believe I love him either on season on
channel 4 or on BBC I don't know in this
woman Phoebe Waller bridge who's like
she's amazing man she's an icon it's she
she's so good yet it's it's I've watched
a couple of those I watched Hannah on
Amazon oh yeah yeah yes that I watched
tin tin star with Tim Roth oh I didn't
hear about that yeah that's on there is
that's just weird
yeah he might like he's like a he's like
a there is in Canada uh-huh he's like a
British cop like err like it's weird and
the first thing is like to see shits in
Canada
country Canada like cut like in the
country I had so we he's like a sheriff
but he used to be a criminal there like
a lot of in the country so sick a lot of
like fields yeah yeah anytime I see
fields and crops I'm like all this
shit's gonna be [ __ ] weird it was
gonna be so weird when it's like
Canadian Amish kind of thing so I saw
that one Hannah of course what else was
on Oh sneaky pete which they just
cancelled oh yeah yeah that was actually
I haven't seen it I knew that it was
created by Bryan Cranston yeah first
season was great second series was great
third season I think they were trying to
get the tax credit so they were
everything was written about like oh we
gotta go to LA sure you know which I
think I think ruined it but I think also
the these streaming networks like even
like Hulu Netflix they're not doing more
than three seasons it's funny because
it's like I don't like I wish people and
whatever want to drops on deadline or
Hollywood Reporter
I wish after three seasons they wouldn't
say cancelled rise it's kind of like it
just ended yeah I cancelled feels like
oh we didn't even get to because we're
so used to like our family is it going
on at 75th season you know I mean you
know that's what it is but I really feel
like if you're pitching shows now you
got to go in with like here's the three
seasons and we'll finish in the third
season with this they just don't want to
spend the money because there's no money
coming in yes it's just I hate that they
still say Kim I'm not [ __ ] they should
just put up a thing that says after
three seasons sneaky peek concludes
another phone call I thought I died I
thought what do you call it on man this
is my mom calling - Oh Chris Rock's
calling I got um I got bumped by Chris
at UH at the cellar a couple weeks ago
right and it was Chris rocks
did he bump in over there I mean I got
to go up but like later it was kind of
like it's kinda like he went up and you
know he did his thing and I was just
watching I was like this is great I mean
this it was he was so at the top of his
game
I was I must've been working on
something he was working I was when he
works on it and it's like I've seen it
too like sometimes you know when you see
the early part of it he's like oh yeah
expectations he'll say that you know no
I've seen him go out with a notebook
yeah yeah he doesn't do the Chris Rock
voice yeah and he's just kind of like oh
I love this treinen like he'll just get
like I remember seeing him he had a 911
joke he went up and he was just like the
rebuilding it they're calling it the
Freedom Tower yeah I'm a column never
going in there that [ __ ] blew up twice
look like and and that like like just
deadpan
deadpan he's like what is checking it
out yeah what are they putting
businesses in there what are the
suitcases gonna have parachutes and and
and he's just saying it like that really
like and then you see him a couple
months later and he kind of puts the
Chris Rock voice on he's like the
suitcases will step you know any kind of
like that's up and like does the thing
and you're like oh yeah this is this is
an amazing process which is why I say to
people go watch live stand-up so
fascinating you know and still watch
like you know it's almost even better if
you go watch somebody working on their
[ __ ] anything like because you know
they're specials coming out and then
you're just like oh let me check to see
how how that you know came together yeah
they just do not disturb on the iPhone
it disturbs it just it just disturb me
like [ __ ] you know all these times and I
gotta go to the stairs yeah I'm going to
airplane mode and now it's too late
because I've already started work cuz
we're almost done we're like an hour you
know I mean I'm like this is that's
that's what do you want mom she just
moved back from Spain
oh yeah but she's you know the dementia
is kicking in right now right so it's a
lot yeah so I'm talking about it on
stage that's how I deal with Wow yeah
yeah you know it's tough you know
people have dealt with that so which is
made me worry about my health sure you
know so I've been like going to cryo and
like you know changing my diet and like
you know getting it taking the tumeric
and I'm really interested in Kyle then
oh man you'll love it it's dope yeah you
got to do it there's a great place
called next health I get skate them a
plug but next tell this in Century City
they have one of those Hollywood yeah
I've been hearing like only good yeah
just do it yeah it's just it really you
should just look up benefits of cryo you
know but I do it in its like fuel like
you know it's cold as [ __ ] but like you
feel like you just ran or something it
gives you this you uh you have a good
therapist yes I do
good yeah yeah I'm always like I got it
they're pissed I'm like but some
shopping the plug I'm like here's the
thing though about my my therapist she
just sort of semi-retired and went to
web therapy not enough like that yet I
got you you know I'm gonna send you a
money so I got the hook-up so okay so I
tried it once I tried it once and I was
like I don't you know I mean I was in my
bed and like you know and I was like
this is weird you know I found myself
checking emails and [ __ ] and I was like
oh I should have sat on my couch I
should have put the computer on the
table sat on my couch and just looked at
it like that and like like I was there I
might try it one more time that way to
see but there was some
there's something for me to go to fit I
like going to bear gotta go like the
part of its like if you if you enter
states where you're kind of like in a
low you need to leave the house yeah you
want to get out it's like yes part of
its just like seeing another person yeah
it's yeah and it's this person that you
trust you know and they know everything
about you if you've been going for like
you know cuz I would go into this lady
for like over a year yeah I mean so it's
like you know you know I I even talked
to her about material I wouldn't be like
I'm trying to talk about these things
and it's just like I don't know what
words to find out where it's coming from
why I'm you know talking about it you
know yeah they're just dealing with my
mom and dealing with you know what would
the break-up and you know and then I
might just stuff I have with family it's
just I've been dealing with a lot of
[ __ ] yeah and it's just like it really
is like you know you go uh there's this
person you know the best part about it
is here's somebody that I don't have to
listen to them yeah and you know and
they're not gonna feel bad that's the
best you know nothing about it they're
not gonna feel bad that I'm not like so
is everything okay with you are you are
you doing okay they're not gonna be like
oh talking about you again I got him why
would I don't understand how people fall
in love with their therapist yeah yeah
why would you ruin that perfect
relationship you just get the dog yeah
the second you fall in love you gotta
hear her tell me about your day your
therapist the woman yeah would you see a
man therapist yeah I it doesn't matter
it doesn't matter I just preferred that
like you know I'm a mama's boy
I guess does probably part of it I've
seen both and I can't quite in jiffy
yeah why or why I'm more comfortable
with yeah I can't be more comfortable
the guy
I can't tell it's gonna be the Muslim
kickin in really good advice for men
know there was something about there was
one therapist I saw who I kind of felt
like you see more than one yeah bounced
around it like I said it out like I've
done a little bit like who's the
location yeah I'd seen one dating yeah
you kind of have to right because it's
like they don't they're not some of them
are bad
yeah it's like comedy or anything this
person's like you're saying cuz for me
the month a reason why I stayed with the
one yeah you real quick before you tell
me this is that because I've started
telling her about my life and she said
oh you have an exaggerated sense of
responsibility yeah and you're like okay
she gets me no I mean I saw one who was
it was just sick some weird energy was
going on between us oh I was kind of
like she would like say stuff like you
look very handsome today or something
like that and I was like wow what's
going on here there was another one I
saw who was good but she'd like move and
I saw this dude that was who was
actually really cool because we've got
each other I'm like dude stuff and then
then now I'm with someone I just test it
out like a couple and then I found and
she's like really cool maybe I should
have done that maybe I didn't you know I
know your therapist went to the web but
yeah yeah I guess so totally problem
with is like starting over I know
but starting over you know I packed so
much [ __ ] and I feel like I have to like
I'd be like okay let me catch you up you
know okay third grade supposed to do no
I think you just start with where you're
at today and like a good one will kind
of know what she needs to know from
before all right right maybe I get notes
from the other one you pass your chance
for my file but it would be great to
like office looking at your file and
just kind of like what you would share
about yourself today versus what you
would share about yourself two years ago
there's different things that's true
you're a different person I feel like
and I feel like I have like a therapy
like you know there's a there's a you
know way a way of being in there now I
know
okay what do you think of that you know
so you have like a you know what I loved
one of the my favorite things is talking
to someone having a very high level
intellectual conversation with someone
yeah that was my favorite part about it
yeah like really like talking about like
the whys
here and like why do I think this way
and and like it's it's actually your
last joking you're special is one of
those things right it's that's the kind
of conversation down the Y yeah that's
the kind of conversation you would have
with somebody that is has to be on a
high level because if not they're gonna
take it the wrong way are they gonna be
like digging in their feelings are they
gonna be like what are you saying
they're gonna judge you know it's like
when you can take a thing say something
and then actually intellectualize it
mm-hmm and then discuss it and then
frapp all that and just deal mm-hm you
know that's what I say you do with
comedy to to mean I think a good tip for
comedies
yes intellectualize why this is funny
why you thought about this where where
did you come up with this like well you
know where is it going what's the who's
the real subject of this intellectualize
the whole thing and then once you
understand it it's in your subconscious
then you forget about all that [ __ ]
and then you just do it cuz now you're
gonna be raw and yes coming from that
real authentic place yeah no man it's uh
breaking that stuff down is so fun and I
don't know how deep down the rabbit hole
you've got or how la you've got I don't
know if you've dipped in there like
energy healers or anything like that
well I haven't got I'm not there yet you
don't you [ __ ] with crystals ever no you
on that crystal [ __ ] oh my god one time
I met this girl who was like a wicked
dude I'd like tell her like you know
she's like you're Muslim and she's like
oh my god I know I
it must be crazy I know exactly you're
going through like I'm a witch I'm like
what do we how are we things we put up
with Wiccan oh it's so interesting you
just should go with it you know healing
and all that keepin my tote I'm just
checking it out I'm seeing what's going
on I'm not you know this stuff reminds
me of sushi oh yeah
yes just like sushi no you like you know
you have to you find the perfect sushi
you start eating different types of
roles you go from the California roll to
like now you've got just
one piece of fish on the plate and
you're like it's like so I'm getting
there I need a I need a $20 single piece
of bluefin Toro yeah I'm doing because
I'm doing like what do you call it like
taking supplements now you know I feel
better I'm losing weight I'm down four
or five pounds I'm like so I'm like okay
you know I mean I saw so that's I feel
like that's the next step because my
therapist always tells me about you need
I need to meditate yeah you gotta yeah
I'm gonna do you should try Islam
honestly like just pray you know I'm
sure you felt it when you went to Saudi
heard that call to prayer
oh that's right we didn't talk about how
I went to Saudi yeah I did go to Saudi
it was it was it was fine
you know like it just did I difference
between going now and going say ten
years ago when I went right the
difference is like you know both ten
years ago they had the religious police
yeah and you couldn't do shows out in
public you had to go to consulates and
you know everything was underground sure
this time they got a festival going on
and there's an did you music playing and
the Backstreet Boys were there what are
you were you able to curse no they
specifically said it was a hard line no
sex no religion no politics so I had
nothing to talk about it was cool what
45 minutes you talking about your mom no
no I did my same material I just took
out those things I just realized as I
was doing the material I was like oh I
curse here for no reason
okay and you know and I just took that
out you know I just feel like all my
stuff is sexual or political right it
wasn't very much I'm kind of like I'm
yeah I do
because I was thinking of going and I
was I wanted to go I was actually down
to do the challenge it didn't end up
working out schedule wise but I wanted
to go and I was like no but that's the
thing is I got thinking you know you say
that I know but then you like actually
because you're enjoying your see the
thing is like we enjoy our freedom here
of being able to say whatever we want as
a comedian
being able to go places but once you
would you go to a place like that what
you really realize is you don't have to
yeah and and and and you being funny is
not predicated on
you know being like this over sexual
cursing every other word you really find
you really find you funny it makes you
more thoughtful in my opinion that's
what I think it's going on with like
what you know when we live through their
me to youth movement you know as male
comedians we just had to be more
thoughtful we can still be misogynistic
in our jokes but they have to you have
dot your i's and cross your T's have no
fear yeah you could still be misogynist
[Laughter]
I know you know I mean like obviously I
go dip into in this special it's like
you can still like it's not like you
have to act like you know you're a choir
boy you know right you can get into it
but it's like you have to address it I
mean I think that was the whole argument
too with like with stuff I mean I heard
a lot of women saying no I want to watch
a Louis stand-up set I just need him to
talk about the thing real quick you know
I need him to get into it see I thought
see I don't agree with that though but I
guess hey women are saying that it's all
good you know cuz I just feel like I
feel like you can't it would make it
like you're saying it was okay like just
talking about it and knowledge hey I did
this did that it's almost like okay so
now I've gotten past that now I'm back
and I'm doing my thing I don't know
what's right or wrong in that situation
it's hard to say it's too soon I don't
think his answer I do think the thing
though is that like if you are gonna try
and come back I would think about it
this way you know we've all done
stand-up in New York and it's so loud
and it's so noisy and it's so crazy and
you'll be onstage and you'll hear like a
siren outside for a while you know you
you're on stage and there's like a cop
car out there and it won't stop and
you're on stage as a comic you've got to
say something about it you have to
address it
because if you don't say something about
the siren everyone's like is he dumb
like there's just like this thing where
it's like oh wait how is he not hearing
what we're hearing it's like when you go
to a play if somebody's earring falls
off and they don't do anything about it
the whole [ __ ] play we all see it I
think that's the whole thing it's like
you get up there and it's like okay we
know you have brilliant takes on things
and think you're not gonna give us a
brilliant take on the siren that is
you're you know a legate and all these
things like like dude this is what we
want at the very least I could see
feeling that I don't want to be
disrespectful to them or you know like
make it you know just be so you know
flippant about it you know what I mean I
wish I could say that I thought it was
being that thoughtful I think he just
kind of doesn't give a [ __ ] anymore I
don't know if your if everybody tells
you you're a pariah yeah then you just
go okay I guess that's what I am so let
me just own it I just think he should
call in though just don't pop in yeah
that's all I'm saying just don't pop in
yeah just say I'm gonna do a show and
here's where it's gonna be yeah his fans
will show up yeah people who do want to
show up yeah yeah but if you're somebody
that's like you know imagine you're
somebody you didn't know yeah oh you're
like really against or you've had a bad
experience and then here comes a person
like that and that it's getting like
cheers and applause and like like
nothing happened it make make certain
people feel a certain way so let them
look at the list and make a choice but
if you see his name on a list and you
show up to the club shut the [ __ ] up if
you uh woody ate you up and he was like
dude let's go on tour together let's go
to Europe oh that would be hard part of
me is like I don't know that's a tough
one damn why would you put me in a spot
like that
[Laughter]
that would be that would be a tough one
I'd have to think about it right think
about it because what would you do
I wouldn't I just because that but I was
real fast he said I would ask the
question I don't know my god I'd never
know I would I mean but that's like I
would say well sorry man I'm just busy
with that yeah listen to you know I
would just kind of like go it would be
really tough like you have a really
tough like you know cuz like I think in
you're always on series and stuff so I
think like if you were on a series you'd
be like okay cool I can just say no I
could be like easy
[Music]
the sucky part about it is is like you
know it's like it's a great opportunity
for a comedian yeah I'm a comic he's
gonna have a big crowds it's gonna be
interesting people in the crowd so you
think of it that way but the sucky part
about it is people are gonna treat you
like you did what he did
sure and that's the part where you go I
don't know if I want to deal with that
sure yeah it all gets caught up and then
it's like am i co-sponsoring this thing
in my sponsors right right right and of
course that would never be the thing I
think we're all like you know I think
this if you want to talk about and I'm
not saying it's all in the same realm
but like just the idea of the art and
the artists and except you know separate
I mean obviously like that stuff I I had
talked about drought a bunch I mean it's
it's it's stuff we all deal with and
kind of try to figure out and yeah we're
trying to sort through words like man I
do like the Joker oh man I do like the
song well I do like the thing yeah yeah
from the art but I saw Bill Maher
talking about it on his show he said he
was just saying like you know we're you
you know we're adults so we can separate
the difference between you know what the
artist would did and what you know what
what the art is right you know but it's
just you know not everybody that's what
I'm talking about when you're having
like a really high level intellectual
conversation there are some people that
are hard lined there's no great area for
them they just they live their life
black and white it's right and there's
wrong and I just I'll never live like
that because I know that there's nuance
in the world yeah there's there's
there's and but yeah I mean there's
certain things where it's like yeah I
mean when it comes to him I wish he it's
hard to watch if you don't address it
that's just that's just what it comes
out for me for me like as someone who's
like a fan of comedy a fellow comic of
this and that I'm like yeah I don't I
don't think I'm gonna watch and I
understand the others to push back on
that is that so he addresses this thing
and then it makes it okay like it's gone
away now so now I could just go ahead
and be funny now that you're like now I
can he's made it okay to laugh at him I
don't think it ever makes it okay I
think it I think it um I think it just
makes it more real
it just feels dishonest talk about you
where it's like well the whole point of
comedy is truth I'm not going to comedy
to get a saint right I'm not going to
comedy comedy
[ __ ] baseline we're pieces of [ __ ] the
guy you think isn't is you are I am
we're pieces of [ __ ] yeah I love that
phrase about we are pieces of [ __ ] and
so what I'm coming to you it for is not
a sermon is not to be on the right side
of things I'm coming to you for the
truth and so when your bit is
genius-level truth takes but then you
are completely ignoring this other truth
I'm like well this is in or avoiding it
yeah this may be his truth is something
that people wouldn't want to hear sure
but say yeah I mean like maybe he maybe
he is maybe he is at these shows that
gives now no one's recording that's true
but I think when he first came out his
only take was like you know I lost a lot
of money doing the thing and it's kind
of like well that's not what I want it's
not what I'm here to hear you know man I
just had a situation yesterday talked
about being a piece of [ __ ] you know you
get on tinder you know I mean so like so
sometimes people they on their tinder
they put like oh this is my Instagram
yeah so this cute girl she was young 20
or something you know I mean and she's
like so I see her Instagram and she's
like I'm an artist hit me up if you want
if you're serious about buying my art so
I go to her Instagram you know she dope
but the arts dope yeah I'm like you know
chocolate mango fourth then I go too far
[Laughter]
I'm not even ashamed of they give us
like I just you know took a shot you
know just being like you know whatever
but then it was like you know but then
it just turned into an uncomfortable
like I was like you know what it was it
was like cuz would the lesson I learned
is like you got to get a swipe back
because that says I'm okay with talking
to you I jumped into water cold there's
some older guy so this she's
mad at me she's going in on me and then
she blocks me that her friend hits me up
you creep
Bo's she called me a bozo in like you
know oh hey hey I'm a piece of [ __ ] I'm
not a bozo that was nice I believed
because I was like I get this I get that
women are uncomfortable and men make
women uncomfortable all the time
especially young women and then and then
they have no they have no nuance in the
world everything's black and white for
them they can't even like they can't
even intellectualize anything they're
just so [ __ ] stupid you know I mean
when you're young people you know I mean
it's like you're intellectually dumb you
know it's not their fault they're
learning how to like you live in the
world and all this kind of stuff you
know so there so I had to be like hey
you know sorry I made you uncomfortable
and then it's like the dude girl put the
conversation on the Internet [ __ ] you
know my stupid pickup lines look really
dumb you know and then she's like she
won't let it go like you know it's not
my fault and I was like okay I said
[Laughter]
[Music]
inappropriate so now [ __ ] off I will
though it a certain point I'm just like
hey you know yeah I acknowledge look I'm
talking about it on my part you know
it's exactly my point like seeing you
break down that interaction would just
be really interesting yeah I think a lot
of people have had that interact and
it's and that's again like that's kind
of a good look dude it's not I'm not
trying to kick someone while they're
down or whatever a lot of people in that
situation or down like it's not a good
you know whatever but like it's all
about just like give us a breakdown of
the thing you know if you're gonna get
on stage just give us a break now
because it'll be interesting to hear
that's that's all I want I guess I know
what you're saying yeah but but just
prepare yourself that the breakdown
could be the thought could be from him
and I'm not saying that this is what it
is yeah but there is a world where the
thought was like I didn't think it was
that bad sure I mean and that's and I
get that
you know I'm that's such a place to live
that there are people that are like oh
yeah this you don't understand
you know the powerless feeling then you
go down that rabbit hole and it's honest
that how people react to that is honest
and I'm just saying he may not want to
deal with that I get it I guess why I'm
saying it's like if you know that's what
I'm saying it's like people's feelings
are valid you know so like this young
girl who feels like you know you know
you know she's beautiful she's got
bikini pics on her Instagram and she
just you know it's okay to be I just
want to be young and sexy it doesn't
mean that I want some old creep [ __ ]
trying to you're trying to [ __ ] me or
whatever
you didn't mean so I get it I'm like my
bad you know I mean I lost myself for a
second yeah I'm owning it and I'm just
trying to I'm moving past it you know to
me but it's like you go less and learn
you know but it's like you know cuz you
know it's hard for guys to really
understand that female perspective it is
and we're never really gonna get it
we're never gonna get that's why it's
like you wanna you know like I think our
responsibilities start to be like as the
stuff is happening where it's like okay
you have a thing happen I have anything
happen my job is to like thoughtfully
and like you were saying before
vulnerably like talk about this thing
right because that's it like we're like
we it's tough to like police people like
like you don't want a police obviously
men don't wanna please women men I'm not
gonna police other men and be like yo
bro Louie go do this thing or do
whatever right that's not who the [ __ ]
am I who the [ __ ] am I to tell him what
it's like give you a I'm a [ __ ] punk
ass like [ __ ] like the go tell and hey
man you should really like whatever but
with the only responsibility we have is
to like in our own work be as vulnerable
as we can and like if we are in the room
with someone to kind of be like at least
encourage a dude like as guys to guys
like hey dude maybe try and take it this
way you know but at the end of the day
like I'm not gonna tell you like tell
you how to do your thing or how to live
your life but like we just we were all
[ __ ] trying but I was talking to a
buddy of mine we're in the hallway when
me too just started and it was heavy and
it was like Weinstein you know everybody
was like oh [ __ ] it's over now though
right
it was a moment like like a month ago I
was talking someone's like we get
everyone is gonna spark them up my but
this is one buddy my he they're in a
group of guys talking about it he says
you know I've never crossed the line put
up it right up to it and that's what I
said to him I said hey man don't ever
say that out loud again because that's
such a guy perspective to think that
like listen if you're at the border of
anywhere you're in a shitty part of town
okay just so you know like you were
there you know so it's like but that's
like what I'm saying is like it's hard
as a guy to understand so I think you
know it's just like the nuance of
flirting and like you know what people
want to hear it's like I'm awkward and
weird and like yeah and like here's the
thing too is like one thing that would
work with one where one girl would
clearly see I'm saying things that are a
joke sure and I know this rapport is
happening she's like I you're so stupid
you're funny and it's like that kind of
flirting another one might be like do
you think these kind of things work with
women in mobile and it was all this you
know did that that kind of vibe so I was
like mmm lesson learned but I'm not
gonna necessarily change myself but you
just had to change like how you go about
things like this will again I freely
acknowledge like I I dipped into a pool
that was cold as [ __ ] yeah it's also
important it's important to like also it
puts precedents on like in-person
interactions you know because so much
gets lost online oh my god like a lost
in translation man I also still think
just the best way to meet people is like
through friends and like just know the
network visit I'm not upset with people
that still want to meet the do my thing
is this though get off of it immediately
and then like meet at a public actually
FaceTime FaceTime is good too FaceTime
is like it's like you really get a sense
you maybe sometimes like I don't find
yep yeah you know I mean so I we do
suggest that but but this man um we're
big sponsors of FaceTime here I know
FaceTime I feel like we could talk
forever I
I just want to know you're busy dude and
you know cuz now he's even got an
assistant I don't know the Fertile by
the way the first time I talked to this
[ __ ] was today when he was like
hey dude I'm 15 minutes away but up till
then it's like I'm dealing with his
[Laughter]
boozy [ __ ] man I was so funny -
cuz I was like I was emailing her and
she was like you have this thing
tomorrow with Eric Koston oh man I
should have just because it was like so
many things came for the thing but I was
like no I could have just texted so I'd
be I actually do owe you an apology
but by the way from doing this as long
as I have doing now that this will be
like episode 39 I think it's gonna be I
get people are busy and I know when you
say Mitch an assistant that meant that
you're actually gonna show like I want
to do it pushed off on an assistant or a
publicist yeah I know that they're
trying to schedule like I actually want
to do it yeah so don't know apologize I
totally appreciate that well that was I
mean dude it's not even it's like that
but it's also like some big guy I might
some people got my number that shouldn't
have had oh my good thing and not
everything I say is loved by all all
that being said I'm still a punk-ass
[ __ ] and so no but I appreciate that I
appreciate you come in and I just want
to say again your show is fantastic it
really is and I really hope you get an
Emmy nomination for all of it I hope you
get an Emmy nomination for writing
directing and acting all things because
I thought it I thought you did a
fantastic job but I read an article
where they were like why Brian Romney
needs a Emmy nomination so it's there
the specials good if you didn't listen
if you if you really want to see some
vulnerable feelings because that's the
name of it you know you're gonna see it
in this you know I mean so you know make
sure you watch that that's on HBO
Romney's on Hulu and you could probably
you you do stand-up right you're around
town I'm getting yeah I'm trying to get
up a bit this summer yeah well I came
from I know
trying to get the show back up and then
yeah but I'll be don't let you ride
don't let you rock Carmichael oh you
hate stand up okay no no I love him so
don't let him know let's do it
underwater he's trying to find a way to
do it different pitches you the
underwater thing you should do it with
him you know I get him now just last
thing he said to me what I said I wanted
him to direct my special I said how
about you do you know you know but he
doesn't [ __ ] with people under 30 over
30 if you over 30 Drock are gonna [ __ ]
with you so he but he said I feel like I
would want to have this exact what he
said I'd want to have some fat black
women on decided in the crowd and during
your set they go and then I have to
interact with them and when he first
said that I thought he was [ __ ] crazy
I get it now I totally and I actually
think that would be hilarious for me to
say something off-kilter
and have an honest reaction from a group
of black women going like this boy crazy
you know I mean am I crazy and then like
imagine how raw and vulnerable that
would be I mean the guy's brilliant man
you know what I mean
he just sees the world in a different
way man yeah he's like to me like he's
like neo and he sees the matrix and I'd
slay that [ __ ] but anyway I'm gonna
have him on to baby if he's not too busy
when it's public when this publicist
hits me about Noah's real he did he send
you know not yes he just won't respond
you know even though we go out and I
told him we're family you could just say
no just say no but he's still trying to
Hollywood me I [ __ ] punch him in his
face but Romney use of fantastic special
fantastic show and I thank you for
coming on and you know let's do it again
after season two I would love that
yeah and again because we'll talk more
basketball a good you know this new
clipper fan over here are you gonna you
way to the Lakers
well they yeah I'm with the Lakers right
now I think between between now and the
next
on the show I probably will have you
leave the Nets around me mad which makes
sense because that's where you're from
yeah I'm gonna play through a lot of
different teams and I'll give various
jerseys and hats and socks and few socks
is oh no someone's really there well
we'll go to the game together one time
okay okay all right all right so anyway
guys thanks for watching good for with
Griffin make sure you subscribe I'll
have all his information in the
description I'll have you know all the
usual stuff you know like share and I
appreciate all that stuff and a member
if you want to send me the fan art and
look at this great new fan art I got
here this is great it lights up I didn't
light it up and he up to this for my
gaming thing for Griffin gaming and you
know I got great card somebody get some
shelves you guys have been you know you
see in the growth and look look at the
fantastic guests I'm getting it
thanks again for watching therefore
Griffin and I'll see you next week
[Music]